alors bonjour à tous je m'appelle félix
et donc comme
vous présenter mon talk que j'ai appelé
humblement la raclette pour sauver la
planète
je vais commencer très simplement avec
cette personne que vous connaissez
sûrement qui s'appelle great attenberg
elle a fait récemment un discours assez
émotif assez émouvant un des sommets de
l'onu et je voulais vous la présentez
pas déjà pour vous en parler pour ceux
qui ne la connaissent pas encore et pour
vous dire que nous sommes en quelque
sorte collègues et nous avons même si
nous avons des objectifs qui sont
similaires nous avons des moyens
d'action qui sont différents même si
elle elle va commencer à attaquer moi je
vais plutôt essayer de de simplement
informer et prévenir
donc pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
encore je vais vous parler de ce qu'on
appelle le réchauffement climatique
c'est un phénomène qui est naturel mais
qui a été amplifiée ces dernières années
en raison de l'homme comme on peut le
voir sur ce schéma qui a été donnée sur
le site du monde
le soleil émettent des rayonnements
solaires qui viennent frapper la terre
la terre var et mettre ses rayonnements
solaires dans tout dans toutes les
directions
ces rayonnements qui auront été réunis
vont être bloqués par la parole
la clac clac où est ce qu'on appelle la
couche d'ozone qui est composée
principalement de gaz à effet de serre
et ses rayons bloqués vont venir
réchauffer la terre évidemment plus il
ya de gaz plus il ya de riom bloqués et
donc plus la terre se réchauffe
on va continuer très vite avec quelques
chiffres accablants pour tenter de vous
effrayer
donc je commence par cette diapositive
0,8 et 4,1 degrés 0,8 c la hausse de
température qui a été observé entre ici
et 1950
la température est oubliée a déjà
augmenté de 0,8 degré et 4° c la
température théorique
qui pourrait être atteinte d'ici l'eau
d'ici les horizons de 1100 dont 4,8
degrés pour nous les humains c'est peu
mais pour beaucoup d'autres espèces
c'est beaucoup on pourra le voir second
diapositives une piscine olympique deux
ou trois pistes olympiques c'est une
quantité d'eau qui font chaque seconde
de tous les glaciers et les banquiers
qui sont au pôle sud et au pôle nord
évidemment pour la plupart d'entre elles
ces glaces de ressaut ne se reformeront
jamais elles vont donc dans l'eau et
donc dans l'eau dans la mer qui dit dans
la mer dit augmentation du niveau de la
mer et on peut parler jusqu'à un mètre
une augmentation de 1 m toujours d'ici
l'horizon 2100 un mètre d'eau en plus ça
veut dire que certaines villes côtières
se verront totalement rayés de la carte
évidemment ce n'est pas un tsunami ce
n'est qu'un seul maître on ne parle pas
de l'atlantide mais des villes comme new
york auront de l'eau à peu prés
jusqu'aux genoux et c'est très
problématique vous pouvez vous pouvez
bien vous l'imaginez ensuite on va
parler des espèces animales et végétales
qui vont être amenées à disparaître un
tiers un tiers d'ici 2100 et ça c'est
facile à comprendre quand votre camp
votre environnement change eh bien il
est très difficile de s'adapter surtout
que s'adapter en sentant pour une espèce
végétale ou animale
c'est trop rapide pour elle elle ne
pourra pas suivre la plupart vont donc
mourir
nous allons maintenant nous intéresser
aux causes
qu'est ce qui cause les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre plus particulièrement
du méthane et du co2 quelles en sont les
causes
à leur première cause les transports le
transport et comme on peut le voir il y
à plus de 60 2% de ces de ces gaz émis
par les pas les transports qui viennent
de transport qui sont de deux types
véhicules particuliers donc tout ce qui
est des déplacements personnels comme la
voiture comme la moto deuxième cause
c'est les l'exploitation d'énergies
fossiles et principalement les centrales
au charbon
comme vous le savez les centrales à
charbon brûle le charbon pour chauffer
de l'eau qui va faire tourner les dd des
turbines
sauf que ce charbon en brûlant et mais
une quantité astronomique
oxyde de carbone qui se retrouvent dans
l'atmosphère et finalement l'ennemi
public numéro un l'élevage
on ne dirait pas comme ça mais c'est
bien nos bonnes vieilles vaches qui
polluent le plus notre atmosphère
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée il y à
1,4 milliard de vaches et chaque vache
produit 100 kg de méthane par an en
pétant les cochons al'inverse n'en
produisent qu'un seul kilo alors
maintenant que je vous ai bien effrayé
et informer je me posais une question
toute simple pourquoi est ce que
personne ne réagit pourquoi y at il si
peu d'action autour de nous et surtout
pourquoi cela n'intéresse personne
eh bien je vais vous répondre deux
choses la première est très simple à
comprendre
imaginez vous vous avez tout construire
vos mains vous êtes un riche un riche
chef d'un riche chef d'entreprise et
maintenant voilà que quelqu'un vous
demande de tout abandonner et de passer
à l'écolo c'est impossible
personne ne peut le faire c'est bien
trop dur et la deuxième raison est lé
plus physiologique
elle est interne c'est comme une
réaction quand le danger est loin
il est très difficile pour nous réagir
si un prédateur s'approche de nous il
est facile pour nous sentir mais si je
vous dis que les glaces fondent au pôle
votre réaction et est trop lente c'est
trop lointain événement trop lointain
pour pouvoir réagir mais alors si je ne
peux vous faire peur et je ne peux vous
convaincre que par les mots quelles sont
les options qu'il me reste eh bien j'ai
essayé de choisir l'option suivante vous
convaincre par mes actions mais action
sans me vanter ne sont vraiment pas
compliqué à réaliser ne change pas mon
mode de vie ont un petit impact mais
réalisée à une très grande échelle
elle pourra en avoir un bien plus grand
première action réduire sa consommation
alors être écolo ce n'est pas régresser
ce n'est pas tout réduire il faut
réduire intelligemment d'abord essayer
de réduire ces transports
j'essaye de privilégier le bus ou le
vélo ou même la marche à pied ensuite je
m'habille au lieu de chauffer mon
appartement je mets un pull ou même un
bonnet et pour vous dire il faisait
tellement froid ce matin j'ai même mis
un leggins où mon jean ensuite réduire
son électricité
si vous n'utilisez pas par exemple une
télé eh bien vous avez le droit de la
débrancher plutôt que de mettre en
veille
pareil pour votre ordinateur il y a
plein d' appareils qui consomment même
lorsqu'ils sont enlevées même branché il
consomme et finalement essayé de réduire
la quantité d'eau que vous utilisez
essayer de prendre des douches
privilégier les douches aux bains et
essayer de réduire la quantité d'eau que
vous utilisez par exemple en éteignant
le robinet quand vous vous savonnez
ensuite consommons plus verre consommé
plus vert qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire continuer à consommer mais
orienté sa consommation pourrait essayer
de diminuer les gaz à effet de serre que
ce que j'aimais premier point
l'alimentation
tout d'abord on va parler de
l'alimentation qui est saisonnière
disons chaque légume comme vous le savez
est récoltée à une certaine période dans
l'année et manger des tomates en hiver
ce n'est pas seulement le fait qu'elle
soit mauvaise mais aussi elle devrait
récolter sous serre ou alors importée du
maroc ou d'espagne ou même de plus loin
encore pour les fruits exotiques et tout
cela aimait beaucoup de gaz à effet de
serre
donc essayez vous procurer un calendrier
des fruits et manger des fruits et des
légumes en fonction de la saison où vous
êtes et ensuite essayer de consommer
plus local si vous avez par exemple une
amap ou quelqu'un qui produit des fruits
et légumes près de chez vous non
seulement ils seront moins chers mais en
plus ils devront ils auront un impact
qui est bien moindre sur la planète
ensuite parlons viande je voulais dit
tout à l'heure une vache produit 100 kg
de méthane par an un mouton 6 kg et un
cochon un kilo pour ne pas parler des
poules qui n'en produisent quasiment pas
alors si vous voulez plutôt que de
prendre une bonne pièce de boeuf
prenez-vous plutôt une bonne pièce de
porc ou alors un barbecue et finalement
je recycle les déchets ce n'est pas très
compliqué ça ne me coûte pas plus cher
et même ça réduit la quantité de ma
poubelle attardons nous maintenant sur
un dernier point que j'ai intitulé dé
polluer l'atmosphère
je n'aurais qu'une seule enfin je n'ai
je n'effectue qu'une seule action
elle n'est pas très compliqué j'ai
installé sur mon ordinateur et mon
téléphone un moteur de recherche qui
s'appelle et causeur le principe est
simple
ecosia se rémunère lui-même via les
revenus générés par les pubs et tous ses
revenus générés sont investis à 100%
pour planter des arbres alors pourquoi
planter des arbres et bien parce que un
arbre convertit les gaz à effet de serre
méchants entre guillemets en dioxygène
qui est plus qui est beaucoup moins
inquiet qui est respirable pour tout le
monde
passons maintenant à la partie que vous
attendez tous pourquoi la raclette et
bien faisons donc une autopsie de notre
de notre ami les raquettes d'abord des
pommes de terre des pommes de terre ça
pousse souvent c'est un fruit un légume
qui ce qui se conserve très bien
vous pouvez donc vous procurer des
pommes de terre quasiment peu importe la
fin quelle que soit la saison dans
laquelle vous vous trouvez du jambon
c'est du jambon cru issu donc de porc
que ce soit du salami du jambon cru tout
ce genre de choses et le fromage soit et
du fromage de vache mais ils
représentent une infime production la
production de l'est ne représente que 20
% de l'utilisation des vaches et 80%
restants des vaches sont destinés à
l'utilisation de leur viande
les cornichons légumes en boîte pour
vous pouvez vous en procurer en magasin
l'appareil à raclette il fonctionne à
l'électricité qui ne m'aimaient donc
aucun gaz à effet de serre finalement
comme on peut le voir c'est carton plein
pour la raclette
j'arrive au bout de mon talk je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté jusque là
j'espère que je vous aurez un petit peu
convaincu et n'oubliez pas c'est en
gagnant de petites batailles que l'on
porte des grandes guerres
[Applaudissements]